there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hey folks it's us again and
it's episode 118 yeah there are really a
lot of these we're just like that's okay
yeah but yeah so anyways we decided like
I said you know I said before that I
kind of like to go back and forth
between like just true-crime and since
we did kind of a mystery type thing last
time we're gonna do true crime this time
and again we're gonna do another like
twofer and this one is two cases that I
have always found super super
fascinating just because they're like so
weird and like convoluted and obviously
they were never solved you wrote about
these right in the book I did actually
these are two that were in the first
volume of faceless fell and one of them
took place in 1902 when one of them took
place in 1931 so I'm calling the episode
old time true crime and he's they're
both like really really weird convoluted
unsolved murders that I found very
fascinating and and actually a lot of
other crime writers found them very
fascinating too because they've been
kind of written about a lot speaking of
books which was it unseen hand part -
excuse me yeah face film part - she's
got that in the can yes I so second time
I still have to edit it but ivory
recorded it and it actually ended up
sounding a lot better because you guys
it's like this I keep running into this
technical difficulties and I feel really
bad because this was I I planned for
this to be out like months ago but it's
just I recorded the whole thing and then
like I was editing it back and it's like
a bunch when were super [ __ ] up and
then yeah you know I was getting all
these crackling and all this other kind
of crap I'm like holy crap I'm gonna
have to rerecord this whole thing over
again in between three shows the books
audiobooks graphic
design having to go see three moves
until we're suffering I'm suffering
people to go to the AMC theater three
times they'll probably all right yeah we
got holidays coming up that's how I got
Thanksgiving coming I got two turkeys in
there
we've been chant we are we've been
really hurting for time we're have been
able to do shady movies too often yeah I
made a comment the other day cuz we had
a we had a patron sent us some really
cool movies discs remember that yeah
Jason yeah Jason thank you and we're
definitely gonna do at least uh we're
probably gonna do all of them as
episodes eventually but we're gonna do
um probably do from beyond now yeah
might be from beyond and I want to do
man with two brains too cuz I was like
said that was the one I was most excited
about because I watch and I hadn't seen
it such a long time we've been really
crunched for time this part of the
season so hopefully you know it'll be
over soon once we get this audiobook and
gotta do another show right now and of
course I I had to pull out Kukulcan
again you know don't get mad you know if
I drink during the show okay I mean some
people say alright this is
unprofessional I'm not listening to a
show with got drinking on there
yeah we're seventies talk show yeah Merv
Griffin with it the half the damn
audience's soused Charro's sitting there
well good question drink it
Ricardo Montalban right well I'm
drinking to but it's like usually I'm
reading so I try not to drink too much
during the show because otherwise but
yeah yeah I'm like you know I'm I'm
freaking out enough as it is
yeah like I try to keep like I like to
have a little bit because it's you know
relaxes me and makes it easier for me to
talk because I'm kind of an introverted
person and it's like really hard for me
to talk yeah change that though so a
little well know it still is but it's
like it is easier like if I have a
little bit to drink it'll kind of like
you know maybe talk a little bit but
okay so we already said thank you to
Jason
for the movies that's awesome and like I
said we're gonna be doing some
retrospectives on those in the future
also I would like to give a shout out to
our newest patron who's named Jonathan D
hi
thank you very much John also our patron
Anthony doubled his support yeah thanks
Anthony so thank you very much you guys
that's really awesome and hopefully
we'll have the audio book out in a
couple weeks I'm trying I'm gonna try
and get the editing done before
Thanksgiving we'll see how it goes
because like I said this is a long-ass
book this is gonna I don't even know how
many hours that's gonna be and then the
Amazon company they takes down a couple
couple weeks to go through yeah it takes
four weeks it'll be out before Christmas
for sure but it's like you know
hopefully it'll be out by I think this
is gonna be in terms of quality of
quality the best audiobook that we've
ever put out so it's gonna sound really
good it better we're gonna go back and
reboot the other one so if I if I go if
I go back and like edit everything and
it still sounds I'm just gonna cry yes
some of the earlier ones we did the
audio quality was good enough to pass
standards but just not that good not
that good it was just the equipment that
we had wasn't that good and we just
really weren't on top of our game game
back then so we're gonna go back we're
gonna relaunch all that old stuff second
edition audio books yeah I mean like I
said this is you know it's gonna take me
a long time to do because like I said
these these are very time-consuming cuz
it's not like I can just like spend a
whole day working on that or you know
whole days working on that I have a
bunch of other should I gotta do too so
you know we try to squeeze it in what I
can get it and yeah that was all we had
to do we could get it done quick just
the scheduling yeah okay you know like I
yeah so that's you know but it'll be up
eventually I swear and I feel bad like
if you're if you wanted one but I swear
it's it's gone it's coming couple weeks
all right so let's talk about a couple
of these weird true crime cases now have
you read my first faceless villain vol 1
then you have read a little bit about
these two cases and like I said these
are two that I get asked about a lot
when I do other podcasts and these are
two that I ox that I actually find
really interesting too so hopefully you
guys will also find them
interesting now I was actually gonna do
the Wallace case first but I think I'm
gonna do Norah fuller first just in the
interest of being chronological you tell
me about this one I don't remember if I
did or not okay we'll see um okay so
actually this took place in San
Francisco in 1902 our victim is Eleanor
fuller better known as Nora she was
actually born in China her dad was a
seaman weirdly her dad disappeared off
his ship like while he was on duty I
don't know if he got like washed
overboard they never tossed him or
somebody toss him overboard here
somebody didn't like his ass I don't
know but it's like they never found him
right so Eleanor's mom had remarried and
then moved to San Francisco but then
they were married for seven years and
then they got divorced so at this stage
in 1902 Nora's poor mother had four kids
no husband and she was kind of like
trying to make ends meet which you know
very difficult nowadays obviously very
difficult back then you could do I do
laundry yeah that's like seamstress yeah
what else could you do prostitute it's
like there wasn't a lot of options right
right so it's like yes so at this stage
Nora is 15 years old all of her siblings
she has three siblings they're younger
so she decides she's 15 I'm gonna drop
out of school and try to get some work
you know to help the family out which
you know what's a nice thing to do now
what she wanted to do was wanted to go
into the theater so that's what she was
trying to do at first she was like kind
of like trying to apply to theater
companies and you know trying out she
could sing and stuff like that but that
evidently didn't work out however in
early January of 1902 she sees an ad in
the San Francisco Chronicle and the ad
says wanted young white girl because it
had to be a young white girl to take
care of baby good home and good wages so
she says okay I can take care of a baby
so she written an e yeah they were
looking for a nanny essentially so she
writes to this person now she gets a
postcard in reply and this post car
says it's from a guy named John Bennett
and he says I want to interview
interviewer you for the position meet me
at this place called the popular
restaurant it's a on Geary Street in San
Francisco either come at 1:00 o'clock or
if you can't come up one o'clock then
come at six o'clock so at about 5:00
p.m. she sets out to meet this person
now about an a little while after that
the phone rings back at her house and
her little brother answers the phone and
he says that it's Nora Nora says oh the
guy wants me to start work right away
I'm at his house at 1500 Geary Street
right so he wants me to start right now
so I'm not coming back so then the
little brother says to the mom you know
relays the information and the mom says
not I like that idea tell her to come
back and she can start on Monday
so then allegedly Nora says okay and
hangs the phone up but she never comes
home later on they find out that there
is no 1500 Geary Street it's a vacant
lot hmm okay
so that's a little weird you must been
waiting down there to snatch her now
here's the interesting thing though now
at the popular restaurant where you know
she was supposed to go meet this John
Bennett person evidently there was a man
in there and he went up to the
proprietor of the restaurant he was
named mr. Kron and said hey there's
gonna be a young girl coming in here
looking for a John Bennett and would you
send her over to my table when she gets
here now they didn't know the guy's name
but that guy had been in there all the
time they said he was a regular like for
the past decade the dude had been coming
in there they said we didn't know what
his name was we called him tenderloin
because he always that's he the only
thing he ever ordered was a porterhouse
steak and then he would eat the
Tenderloin part of it and that's it so
that was the nickname they gave him
because they didn't know what his name
was but they said he was in here all the
time so now they said that he was in
there and then he like went outside like
he was looking for somebody and he was
like pacing up and down and stuff but he
was there for about half an hour and
then he
left now they didn't say that they saw
the girl show up there okay
but he said that his name was John
Bennett and he was waiting for her right
so then after like you know Nora didn't
come home
her mom actually didn't report her
missing for some sources say a few days
I'm saying a whole week I'm not really
sure why that is
um I'm not sure if maybe she thought oh
well I guess she decided to work anyway
and they didn't really want to check on
her or anything but it just seems weird
but she did eventually um she did
eventually report her missing but they
didn't know where she was for like a
month
weird okay now meanwhile like three days
I think it was two or three days before
Norah fuller disappeared this guy whose
name was CB Hawkins or so he said comes
into this realty office and he says hey
I want to rent this house that you have
it was on Sutter Street I think was two
to one one and they asked for references
he's like oh I'm not from around here I
said you don't really have any but the
the rental office said well he looked
respectable enough you know he was very
clean very clean-cut looking and you
know he looked like he had money and
stuff and he paid for a month in advance
so they let him they gave him the keys
and they sent somebody over there to
clean it up and whatever now apparently
this same guy also went to a bunch of
shops around the neighborhood and bought
like furniture and sheets and stuff to
put in this house but only enough for
one room like he bought a mattress he
bought some sheets a couple pillows a
used chair and a towel like that's a
that's it like it wasn't like he was
furnishing a whole house it was just
like one room full right so you know no
one thought anything about that at the
time like I said so then a month goes by
and somebody is you know who has to do
with the realty office is walking by
this property on Sutter Street he's like
you know didn't a guy come in here like
a month ago and rent that because it
doesn't look like anybody's living in
there and at this stage it was getting
to the point where the rent was going to
be due again so they were
okay well let's go in there and see
what's going on so the guy goes in there
and he's like weirdly the whole bottom
floor no furniture nothing in there and
he's like he goes up to the top of his
other rooms no furniture he's like so
there's one room at the end of the hall
and the doors shut so he goes down in
there and he kind of opens door it's
really really dark in there
you know the curtains are drawn and
everything he said he sees like a
brightly colored like piece of clothing
like laying on the floor but he gets a
really really bad feeling and he's like
I don't like this I'm gonna go get a cop
so he runs down to the street he finds a
cop both of them come back up in there
and in that room in that bed that that
guy bought like a month ago is Nora
fuller she's been in there for a month
oh she was here on how did it how come
they didn't smell her what are you what
time the month was this oh it was
January it would have been hot in San
Francisco yeah she should have been
stick well I don't know well I don't
know how far apart like the other
properties were for this particular
place but yeah she'd been in there you
would think when you as soon as you got
into the house though you'd smell it the
room something doesn't sound right about
this story but you know what's dry but
roll yeah the interesting thing is that
I mean when they found her it's so funny
like how how they say this and these old
timey newspapers they said that she'd
been outraged which I assume means raped
yeah um they also said she had been
frightfully mutilated but didn't say how
in particular but so it was some sexual
yeah it right so the only other things
they found in this house like I said
there were no toiletries there were no
nothing like that they said the only
like bathroom article was like a single
towel so this is two different guys the
guy and the rest I'm the guy that got
there not sure about that though okay -
oh yeah Elias right um the only other
thing that they found in this place
where they found her body was um mostly
empty bottle of whiskey
cigar butt and a bunch of junk mail that
was addressed to mrs. C B Hawkins now
çb Hawkins was obviously the the name
that the guy had given to rent the
property and that was the name that was
on the rental agreement
now weirdly one of these pieces of junk
mail had been opened and then somebody
put it in the jacket that was on the
floor that was Nora's like her mom said
that's Nora's jacket that's what she was
wearing when she left the house
so why somebody would open junk mail and
stick one piece of it in the pocket of
her jacket who knows her purse was also
still in there although they didn't find
the postcard that John Bennett had sent
to her liked to come for the interview
even though she had taken it with her
her mom said she took it with her so
they didn't find that so this guy's
renting random houses to live in and
kill girls and he just abandons the
house yeah maybe it just seems really
strange once now when they did the
post-mortem on Nora Fuller's body they
found that she had been given alcohol
that she had drunk some not a lot but
you know some they said now the only
other thing that was in her stomach was
an apple now her mother said well she
ate an apple before she left for the
interview like a month before yeah so
they're operating under the assumption
that she was killed pretty much
immediately after arriving at this
interview or whatever it was that
happened to her so now police are pretty
sure even from the start that the person
known as John Bennett and the person
known as CB Hawkins are probably the
same dude right because they you know
it's it's like because they went around
and like they they asked the guy at the
rental agreement today I mean they said
this is the description that they gave
you know they had a drawing of John
Bennett because they knew him at that
restaurant right they'd seen him they're
like all the times they gave a
description and they showed this you
know the sketch to these people at the
furniture stores people at the rental
office they said yeah that's the same
dude how long did you say he'd been
going to that restaurant um I read ten
years he lived in that area yeah evident
yeah evidently even though like I said
when he went to if this was
indeed the same guy when he went to rent
the thing he said oh I'm not from around
here so I don't have any references but
like I said that margins right he was
probably just lying because he was using
an alias so yeah so all the people like
he had gone to at least like two or
three stores like in order to buy
blankets and sheets and a mattress and
[ __ ] like that
and all those people said yeah that's
the same dude I got a feeling that you
know he raped he raped her killed her
and then he stayed up in there in the
body for a couple days I'm thinking yeah
maybe he was like one of those weird
yeah stand up in there with her for a
while yeah maybe he mutilated the body
after a long time after because he
probably wouldn't have a way to know how
porst post-mortem the mutilation
especially in 1902 yeah he may have kept
her alive for a few days and then killed
her and stayed with her for a few days
and then had fun yeah is why would you
need privacy for that amount of time
just to kill him right woman then why
would you need to rent a house for that
yeah and why not only would you you know
why would you rent a house but why would
you go to the trouble of renting
furniture just for one or buying
furniture stops for one room it wasn't
something quick you know they're gonna
be something he was gonna enjoy for at
least a week I would think yeah it had
to be something like that there had to
be some reason why he was furnished it
he didn't furnish the whole house just
that one room and only the necessary
things you know what I mean Inc he
stayed in there with her alive or dead
he must have stayed in there for a while
or they said she wasn't smelling that
wasn't smelling well I don't know I just
never saw that but he didn't know what
was in there he went out and got a cop
yeah I didn't say maybe he did maybe he
did tell her how I smell something bad
in there well yeah maybe that's what
maybe that's what made him run back into
the street but I don't I bet you she
wasn't dead for I bet she hadn't been in
there dead for a month I bet you she was
only been dead in there for a week
I'm sure bet he kept her for a couple of
weeks but like I said they found the
Apple in her stomach
yeah she could have eaten a different
I've been bringing her food yeah true
it's just seemed weird that her mom said
yeah she left an apple right before she
might have been in sees you in that area
area so they were just everywhere seldom
honest yeah that's possible so she yes
she could have been alive like longer
then yeah I think she was alive for a
while
now that's why he rented that place yeah
now see okay now here's another thing
too now evidently after she was found
dead and they start looking for this
person with these two aliases or so they
think
now she has a friend named Madge that
comes forward and she says that Nora had
actually had like an older boyfriend
whose name was Bennet and that she had
been meeting him on the sly now as far
as is known I think Madge is the only
person that said that I mean nobody else
knew anything about it um one guy that
owned like kind of a grocery store a
hotel or something like that like near
where she lived said that noir I used to
come in there and use the phone in the
store even though she had a phone in her
house so that's kind of seen as another
clue that maybe she was seeing somebody
on the on the sly and maybe this John
Bennett was actually her boyfriend yeah
maybe he found her yeah and Madge said
oh well that whole ad for a nanny that
was in the San Francisco the San
Francisco Chronicle that was just a ruse
to get out of the house to get her out
of the house or her mom wouldn't know
about it which seems a little convoluted
but um you know whatever I don't know if
that's the case but that's also 1900s
that sounds like something that they
maybe they would do maybe it was a ruse
to get out of the house early at the age
of 15 oh I have to work yeah I mean it's
working for her boyfriend yeah I mean
that's totally awesome this might have
been a domestic dispute yeah and I mean
Madge did say later on she's like oh
well I've even covered for Nora a few
times like she went out with the
boyfriend and you know I was supposed to
tell her mom that we were just at the
theaters cast new light on it maybe they
would play getting ready to play house
yeah some kind of argument broke out he
killed her yeah and you know and then
mutilated her but they didn't say what
the details were you know we're not so
we don't we can't see the body yeah he
said this is this is an early 1900s
newspaper and they weren't very reliable
and like I said they oh they used a lot
of euphemisms yeah yeah like I said
you're not sexually violated you're
raped yeah they just assumed that
because she had had sex yeah yeah it's
possible but yes so you know that's the
thing too and and another weird thing is
that that might explain like her
actually knowing this John Bennett
person that might explain why she called
her house and gave them a fake address
yes so they would know not to come
looking for her but then she wasn't
expecting to get murdered obviously
right um you know what I mean but they
were nice to me I don't mean to
interrupt go ahead what we gonna say um
I forgot okay I said well this also
explains something else he'd been going
to that restaurant for ten years yeah
all right that doesn't sound like a
prowling serial killer right prowling
serial killers not you know in a certain
area for too long and he's not gonna use
a place to haunt some kill yeah they use
a place where he's a regular yeah
because everybody saw him this is
starting to me starting to sound like a
domestic dispute yeah I mean yeah this
guy doesn't really sound like a serial
killer type cuz it's like he's not
disguise in his face or anything like
not that I know of
yeah and and he rented a place to kill a
person and then abandoned it it just
sounds unlikely yeah that does seem
serial killers more likely just throw a
woman behind a dumpster or something and
killer killer got bushes and they walk
off happens all the time
yeah that's you know down and dirty and
fast and quick disposable yeah this I'm
starting to lean towards this might have
been intimate a domestic dispute and
like I said maybe he's misreported maybe
he wasn't even intending to kill her at
first no I don't think he was I think it
was an argument or something because why
yes he used an alias but why I mean he
didn't disguise his handwriting because
they saw that the handwriting of CB
Hawkins and this John Bennett person
looked pretty much identical sounds like
he was trying to cover his tracks so
they could run off together and then in
the log and track him down she was
underage yeah I would think under age 4
1900s 15 may have been legal I don't
know maybe it was just a way of keeping
mom from tracking her down yeah so much
law enforcement right that's yeah it's a
possibility and I'm not sure what the
laws were at that
you know different might have been legal
at 13 right in a lot younger back then
so no yeah married very early yeah
now another interesting thing that
happened and this actually occurred and
they thought it was unrelated but until
later on this actually happened about
three weeks before they found Nora Nora
Fuller's bodies about a week after she
had disappeared so evidently there's
this guy who worked at the San Francisco
Examiner and his name or so he says is
Charles B Hadley now he actually
embezzled a whole bunch of money from
the newspaper and then took off now
while they were investigating that at
the time not thinking it was anything to
do with the Nora fuller disappearance
because as I said her body hadn't been
found at this point so they interview
this Hadley person's girlfriend whose
name was Olly blazer and she says that
um she saw the what she call it the
postcard the John Bennett postcard in
the paper and she said that looks
exactly like my boyfriend's handwriting
right so then so she gives the police a
bunch of handwriting samples that are
like yeah that looks just like the CB
Hawkins
signature and it looks just like the
John Bennett signature so we're thinking
this is like a third alias of the same
guy she also pointed out that she's like
he's very well known for being all into
the Tenderloin you know what I mean cuz
at the at the restaurant they called him
tenderloin because that was like what he
ordered all the time and she said yeah
he's like really well-known for that she
said another interesting thing too is
that while most of the time he was
clean-shaven she's like he has a fake
moustache and I've seen him run around
run around wearing it because most of
the people said that he had a moustache
right right and they were even able to
determine where he had bought it it was
like this little shop down the street
from where all he lived he had bought
like a fake mustache there and she said
sometimes he would wear it like on the
street for shits and giggles and she
didn't think anything about it at the
time that was his until guys yeah that
was like his disguise you can't you mean
his disguise I just [ __ ] around
than Clark Kent's disguise Superman's
guys rather and she also said that now
this is like I said this could be a
vindictive ex-girlfriend I'm not sure
but she also said she's like he was very
very interested in the newspaper reports
about the Nora Fowler disappearance
she's like I found it she he took it in
the in the bathroom and like read that
whole [ __ ] and like left it on the thing
it was like super disturbed by it
quote-unquote and she said also after he
left she found some kind of some clothes
of his that had looked like they had
some blood on him like at the bottom of
the laundry pile or whatever so that's
what she said so now like I said this
guy who worked at the examiner who said
his name was Charles B had Lee which if
you think about it that's the same
initials as CB so he was at least
two-timing yeah at least okay yeah so
the more they look into this Charles B
Hadley personal I guess they couldn't
find him cuz he like took off like I
said he embezzled a bunch of money and
he got the [ __ ] out
they also found out that his real name
or at least his fourth alias was Charles
start and this was the first the the
first thing that he was known for he was
actually back in 1889 he had embezzled a
bunch of money from another company back
in Minneapolis so he was a thief too
yeah and he was also accused I don't
think he was ever convicted but he was
also accused of raping a girl another
girl in San Francisco two years prior
nineteen hundred under this other name
Charles start okay so like I said this
is a dude if it's the same guy and like
I said they never found him this is a
guy with perhaps four aliases yeah he
sounds just like a scammer yeah you know
it's kind of a conman scammer now so
every serial killer is some kind of a
scammer but not every scammer is a
serial killer I still kind of think that
I still kind of think this is he didn't
plan to kill that girl
yeah I mean if it was the same guy and
if he did another girl then yeah he
pretty he just had you know tendencies
to my kind of abusive right and yeah you
know in 1900 s you can get away with a
lot of [ __ ] so he probably was pretty
forceful in getting what he wanted which
would amount to strong-arm and women
yeah you know and and lying to him and
conning him to two-timing them you know
kind of kind of guy that you know would
try to run little scams you know maybe
eventually go up to like I was some kind
of weird life insurance scam or bad
insurance scams and setting fires he was
some kind of a crook like that yeah but
because she said he was so interested in
those newspaper reports so that it look
like it disturbed him makes me think
that might have been a one-off yeah
something happened maybe she said she
was gonna go to the police on him or
something like that it definitely does
seem cuz like I said it really doesn't
seem like this is the predator type of
serial killer that's just like picking
random and killed him this wasn't his
main thing it was something that it
happened on the side and it it bothered
him and then he maybe stole some money
and vanished yeah that definitely does
seem he stopped doing that because yeah
it he he vanished after stealing all
that money about a week after she
disappeared yeah so the timing of that
and like I said it was the same guy it
was under a different name obviously you
guys appear easily back then you have
computers in the paperwork all I had to
do was go to another state change your
name probably started a new identity and
then continued on doing scams different
kinds of scams but evidently well there
are a lot of unsolved murders out there
maybe he did some of them maybe he was
building up to something yeah I mean it
does seem like I think that he would
have gotten caught right I never read
anything that linked this particular
murder to any other ones in the area you
know what I mean cuz you know a lot of
times you'll have like a woman that's
killed and then they go oh well there
was another one like five miles away and
it was very similar there it doesn't
seem like there was any of that going on
and the whole thing about him rent
the house and furnishing the room makes
me feel like maybe he didn't intend
maybe he did intend to rape her maybe I
don't think he intended to kill her I
think he intended to keep her as a
girlfriend yeah and then to time with
the other one - sighs I'm so you have a
couple different places to go
yeah and he's using stolen money to do
all this anyway so I think was trying to
set up a network of little dens yeah you
know with a woman at one of them you
know and something happened with this
young one maybe and maybe she said the
wrong thing to him you know about going
to the police if he didn't do this or
that and he's like oh [ __ ] you you know
and got into a fight he hit her and then
she goes well that's it I'm going back
home no you're not I'm gonna call the
police and he killed her yeah something
like that
yes built up to that yeah but this is
early nineteen hundred's you know when
he only a few years later World War one
would have broke out yeah and then there
was also like a Spanish flu pandemic so
I do could just get could have bit died
or vanished in these in in in in the you
know in the things that happened and in
in the early hours it wasn't a good time
yeah you know I think he probably died
although I say that a lot on this shows
I think that dude died well now but
usually if a guy leaves his fingerprints
on something he continues to leave his
fingerprints on something yeah so a lot
of sources that I read said that they
thought he might have committed suicide
suppose like not too long after after he
vanished he doesn't sound like a serial
killer
to me that's what I mean I feel like I
mean because the whole thing here's an
interesting thing - now the fact that he
went to the popular restaurant and the
fact that he ran this ad and he
specifically went up to the owner of
this restaurant that he was in all the
time and said hey a girl is coming
looking for someone named John Bennett
that's me
send her over to the table I wonder was
he like trying to establish some kind of
out yeah because she didn't show up I
don't think at that at that thing so I
don't know if they had some kind of
prior thing where it's like oh well
you're supposed to show up at the
restaurant but don't show up like just
go right to communication and
transportation back then was a lot
harder than xand yeah you couldn't just
like text somebody and she was a young
girl maybe she got lost yeah you know
maybe she was running late maybe that's
what made him mad something like that
cuz they did say that he was pacing back
and forth and he seemed really I think
he expected her yeah yeah but that is it
yeah it's really it's really weird the
way he was like hey I'm announcing what
my name is and he's doing this in a
place that he's been going to for 10
years is just not buying it that this
guy's a serial killer Syracuse was a lot
cleaner than that and like I said I
think I think maybe he wasn't intended
to kill her like no I don't think he was
maybe they were maybe he said well we're
gonna run off together something like
you said she just did something that
pissed him off and then he just like
went off and yeah it escalated into him
right triangle in her yeah I mean I feel
like that's an immediately probably
would end up happening is that the
newspaper exaggerated what had happened
to the body and the girl they said she
was frightfully mutilated but that's
newspaper could say you know I mean a
lot of thing a lot of different things
what does that mean right was she
slapped or was she punched did she had
bruises on her face were breasts cut off
what are they talking about yeah so I
will usually when I was like frightfully
mutilated I think of like Jack the
Ripper yeah like they pulled out oil
cookies that the newspapers of the early
1900s a lot of yellow German journalism
they wanted you to do yeah they wanted
you to read it I was analyzed yeah not
at all what it was she was could have
been and she would just strangled yeah
it could have been but you know like I
said but yeah I definitely do think cuz
you know when I was first writing about
this case I'm sitting there going now I
wonder you know did she really have this
boyfriend and was he really the one but
now like the more I think about it I
think it's true it seems more likely
than because of the whole furniture the
whole rental thing it's like why would
you do that if you're just gonna like he
was gonna he rented that place of stolen
money and he was gonna build a little
love nest there with this girl as a
second home then he was probably gonna
rent out the other the rest of it sure
so and put her in charge of a boarding
house basically and probably run some
kind of business you know I mean he's
doing this with stolen money you
and her as a manager to manage his right
boardinghouse he who sublet the the
rooms was pry something like that
argument broke out he killed her
yeah and he went ran back to the other
woman oh [ __ ] and then washed his hands
of it
and then went back to work stole all the
money and yeah and it's got the [ __ ]
yeah probably cuz he thought they were
on his tail yeah something like that
but like yeah like you said he sounds
kind of moral he sounds a little bit
like HH Holmes yeah it was kind of like
a scammer like a scammer
went on into murder or we're just like
murder people and then they'd be like
well [ __ ] now I got a you know skip town
and like change my name again and I
think it was more money I think it was
an accident
yeah he was in the heat of passion and
planet and I think the newspapers
exaggerated what had happened yeah maybe
or maybe he was just really mad maybe
that's why he was so freaked out by what
the newspaper said yeah I didn't do that
yeah you know that's not what happened I
gotta get the hell out of here
something like that yeah I definitely do
think that's like the more I think about
it the more likely that seems like I
said the only thing they know about this
dude who probably had at least four
aliases was and I don't know I'm not
sure how they know this but pretty much
every source for this I said said they
thought that he committed suicide not
too long afterwards so I mean ah because
he vanished
yeah vanished and there were none any
other crimes that fit that profile yeah
but who knows because
intercommunication between the street
between states in the United States and
the early 90s was bad yeah
she said talking to each other you could
have moved to another state on the same
che and done the same [ __ ] and nobody
noticed yeah cuz you wouldn't like it
you wouldn't be linked especially back
then alright so let's take a break right
now and when we come back we're going to
talk about the fascinating Wallace case
which is so weird that I mean it's had a
bunch of books written about it like
Raymond Chandler was like super into it
like all you're really famous crime
writers oh really it sounds like an
Agatha Christie story it's almost kind
of like the perfect crime but we'll kind
of get into that a little bit later so
for right now let's take a break and
we'll be back in just a couple minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay everybody Ginny's got some new
shirts designs up four of them really
good ones to Atlanta Ripper who put
Bella in the which out the HH Holmes
murder castle and of course demon child
cuz man said he could these are updated
designs I think they look really cool
Jenny did a great job autumn where they
found making Jenny
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out very good
yeah it really good they're very
high-quality shirts Jenny and I we're
sure our own shirts at certain times
when we're trying to put a spotlight on
ourselves and you can put a spotlight on
yourselves if you go ahead and pick up
on these shirts today you guys are gonna
love them links in the description WWL
comm at 13 o'clock yeah so go check out
our store at wwl com / 13 o'clock we got
these four cool new t-shirt designs plus
all our old ones if you'd rather get one
of the old ones but these ones are
awesome and you should check them out
they're also available in women's cut
they look really cute JT's got some so
thank you go check them out
[Music]
okay we're back on the old-time
true-crime double feature
hey rhymes and everything I love that
kind of [ __ ] now we're talking about the
Wallace case now this was also in my the
first volume of the faceless villain and
this was actually one of my favorite
cases in the book and honestly this
seems like a case that a lot of people
really like it's been written about by a
lot of crime writers PD James Raymond
Chandler a bunch of people have kind of
been fastened it's almost kind of like
you know like Agatha Christie and [ __ ]
like that used to write like those
locked room murders where it was like
you know how could this have happened
because just all the details of it just
don't add up you know what I mean it's a
case like that and people are still it
happened in 1931 but people are still
like trying to figure out exactly what
happened in this one cuz there's kind of
it could kind of go either way and I'm
actually not sure how how I feel about
it how I stand on it but so let's set
the scene I'm ready
it's 1931 this is on a street called
Wolverton Street in Anfield Liverpool
England got a guy named William Herbert
Wallace he's an insurance agent for
Prudential he's 52 years old also plays
the violin also a chess enthusiasts he
loves to play chess even though all his
friends say he's not particularly good
at it
but he goes to a club and plays and
matches and whatnot now he has a wife
named Julia they've been married for 17
years most of the sources give Julia's
age as 53 so about the same age as him
however I have seen seen some sources
that say she was actually much older
than that that she was like actually in
her 60s mid to late 60s and that she
lied about her age but I don't know how
accurate that is so she's either the
same age as him or she's
we're considerably older because it was
brought up she was considerably older
yeah I'm just saying I've seen that not
only know how they brought that [ __ ] up
that means yeah so yeah she might have
been like 10 15 years older than hey
yeah
so they've lived together in this house
for a very long time like I said they've
been married for 17 years they nobody
thinks anything about it they seem
normally very quiet they keep to
themselves and stuff like that but you
know they've seemed quite normal
so January 19th 1931
William is supposed to go play at a
chess match at a place called the city
cafe which is where the Liverpool chess
club which he is a member of and they go
and have games there every now and that
now it should be noted that he there's a
little thing in this cafe that says the
names of all the people that are gonna
be in the in the tournament now he had
been scheduled to be in a lot of
tournaments but he hadn't been in them
since like the previous November so a
couple months he hadn't really showed up
to him even though his name was on there
but this time he did show up January
19th now he gets to the Chess Club and
the guy that runs it who was also a
friend of his his name's Samuel Beatty
and he says hey a phone call came in for
you about 20 minutes ago guy says his
name is RM Quatro or qual trough I'm not
sure how it's pronounced he says that he
wants to buy an insurance policy for his
daughter and he says that you should
come to his house at 25 men love gardens
east tomorrow night at 7:30 so William
Wallace says okay well I don't know
anybody by that name and I'm not really
sure where that address is but hey it's
the depression everybody needs money
everybody's hustling so he thinks hey
Commission right
he wanted to buy what for his daughter
Insurance Paul he was a lady well she's
an insurance agent yeah he worked for
Prudential I was like I said so you know
so there's that goes he plays in the
match he goes home now
the following night now he like I said
he is an insurance salesman he's lived
in Liverpool for quite a while and he's
pretty familiar with the city he's never
heard of men love gardens East there is
a
love gardens west there's a middle of
gardens north and there's a men love
gardens south there's also a men love
Avenue so he basically he's like all
right so about a little past it's almost
7 p.m. on the following night he gets on
the tram in front of his house and rides
to one and then he you'd like transfers
to another one now with this stage the
conductor of the Train of the ticket
taker everything like that said now he
started pestering them about would you
guys know where men love gardens east is
I've never heard of that and they were
like well we never heard of it either
but maybe you should get off here or
transfer here so they were like giving
him directions so evidently he's riding
around all over the city like trying to
find this place like he gets off at
various places and then he seems to be
like asking a bunch of people in the
street do you know where Menlo Garden
C's do you know where it is do you know
where it is so everybody says look
there's no such Street you know there's
a south of West and a North but there is
no East for whatever reason it's like a
triangular kind of configuration or so I
read so apparently he's going around
asking everybody in the [ __ ] world
where this [ __ ] addresses and nobody
knows if it was like look man it doesn't
exist I'm sorry
so finally finally about 8:30 8:45 he
decides well ok I guess I'm not getting
a commission and this doesn't exist and
somebody has sent me on a wild goose
goose chase so I'm gonna go back home so
he goes back to his house now the next
time he is spotted he is in the back
alley like behind his house
and his neighbor's the Johnston's
they're leaving they're going out to the
pub or whatever and they see him at his
back door and he seems to be having some
difficulty and they're like hey man
what's the matter and he said I can't
get in my house it's like the doors are
locked and my key isn't working like I
tried the front and now I tried the back
and it's not working and they're like
well that's really weird they're like
yeah well he now the neighbors had a key
to his house which apparently wasn't a
big thing back then because I guess you
know they could look in on your [ __ ]
while you were gone or whatever so they
said well do you want us to go get our
key and we'll try that out and he's like
nah I'll try it
more time so then he tries the back door
but then it opens okay so he's like oh
okay
so he goes in the house he lights the
gas lamps a couple minutes later he
comes out and the Johnson say he looks
real pale and he says come and see she's
been killed so they all go in his house
and his wife has been beaten to death
and she's laying in the front room in
front of the fireplace and hurt I mean
this is like really gross like they even
said him according to Johnson said that
he said look at her brains cuz like her
her somebody had beat her in the head
like 11 times they determined later with
what they think is probably a fireplace
poker and yeah her brains were like
sticking out
she's like laying in front of the
fireplace the doors are locked there is
no sign of forced entry
the only other thing that they said now
one of the dressers in the bedroom like
the drawers were open like somebody had
kind of hat part half-heartedly gone
through them however the safe that um
that William Wallace had in the wall
where he kept his Prudential Insurance
takings for the day like on Tuesdays he
would bring them home and put them at
his little safe he had a little box in
there that safe had been wrenched open
and the box was still in there but it
was empty now he said that there had
been four pounds in there and somebody
took it if it was robbery that's the
only thing that was taken Julia's
handbag was still like land right there
had some money in it had some silver in
it but none of that was taken but
apparently his takings for the day from
his safe were gone he said it was
wrenched open yes so like water with a
crowbar
evidently that's that yeah it must not
have been very strong safe yeah I'm sure
it probably wasn't like I said it was
just it seemed like I haven't seen
pictures of it like I've seen I have a
picture and I'll show put it in the
video but just off the top my head I'm
already very suspicious over this case
I'm thinking this guy killed his wife
well did but you know care so many so
far yeah so far this dude's looks awful
guilty to me okay so they call the cops
and the cops come now at this stage
there had been a police strike so a lot
of the regular cops on the regular beat
were you know striking or had been laid
off so the ones that turned up
not exactly the cream of the crop also a
lot of them were doing double and triple
duty because they were short-staffed so
you know so they have the guys come now
one of the bones of contention is the
coroner comes and he wants to determine
the time of death he does this by
measuring rigor mortis and that's it now
they said no even in the 1930s they knew
that that was not a very accurate
measure they're like no they didn't take
a body temperature she didn't he didn't
check body lividity he didn't do any of
that he basically just said oh well
rigor mortis is x-amount progressed so
obviously bla bla bla now the first
thing he said was that the time of death
was 8 p.m. which obviously means that
William Wallace couldn't have killed her
because he was seen way across town like
on the train it's like multiple multiple
people saw him right so there was that
whole thing so then later but later on
though just for no reason at all he came
out and he decided he's like oh no never
mind actually she died at 6 p.m. however
this is also probably wrong because the
kid who collected the money for the milk
and also a newspaper delivery person
both saw Julia Wallace alive between
6:30 and 6:45 actually the milk kid said
that he even went to the door to collect
the milk money and talk to her because
they both had colds and he remembered
what time it was cuz there was like a
church clock and actually the newspaper
person also saw him standing on the door
you know the doorstep and saw her as
well and knew what time it was so she
was still alive at 6 o'clock
obviously so that obviously wasn't right
either so they never did determine like
what exactly the time of death was so
then no like just like you said because
when somebody turns up dead in a
situation like this it's
pretty much 99% of the time it's usually
the husband the boyfriend that's almost
always with it and it looks like he's
fabricated of alibi exactly and that's
what they thought they said you know it
seems really weird that he got this
phone call the night before at the chess
club that said hey come meet me at this
fictitious address and he's it seemed
like he was going out of his way to get
people to notice him and who would know
about his measly little safe right like
you know I'll get to that
I mean this is all I know right I would
like this is looking awful fishy
although here's the thing though and
here's the thing the neighbors see him
trying to fumble and get into his own oh
I can get in that looks awful yeah they
said that seemed kind of fishy to all
that was he making sure that he was seen
coming in that's all what she actually
leaving and got caught leaving and then
lied you know maybe he was making his
escape who knows
well yeah it's awful fishy right well
that's what they thought - yeah although
it should be noted that the only um you
know the only witnesses they have to him
trying to get in his house where the
neighbors huh you know what I mean so
they it was just their say-so so you
know I don't know but yeah that's
exactly what they thought they said oh
it seemed so convenient that you went
off on this wild goose chase and you
were conveniently gone and so many
people saw you you know but then you
come home and your wife is dead and it's
trying to make it look he's trying to
looks like it looks like he's trying to
make it look like somebody who knows him
sent him on a wild goose chase to to get
his safe
yeah that's what it looks like right
it looks fake right but like I said
that's what the police thought at first
too now they thought it was strange they
said now another thing too is that Julia
they're like look if the husband didn't
kill her that it had to be somebody it
couldn't just be like a random robbery
because there actually had been a lot of
random robberies in the neighborhood and
it has to be somebody who knew them both
it was they actually called them the
anfield housebreaker but they said it
probably wasn't that because julia was
super super paranoid yeah she did not
like strangers so there's like it either
had to be the husband
had to be somebody both knew that they
knew because he would have had to have
known about the safe yeah I hadn't known
about his job and how to get him out of
there right I had to have a way to get
in there without forcing entry right so
they're saying it had to be somebody
that she knew or somebody that had a key
if you find the right person that could
be this could be plausible well yeah and
I'm like I said I'm leaning toward one
thing but I'm not particularly sure now
another thing that kind of led to the
police thinking that probably the
husband did it and then later went off
on this elaborate thing to try to
establish an alibi was that they
actually were able to trace the call
that had been made from RM qual true to
the Chess Club on the night prior to
Julia Wallace being killed now the
reason they were able to trace this call
because that wasn't a thing that they
could really do very easily in 1931 yeah
and did they keep records they said the
reason they could do it is because the
person that called had contacted the
operator and asked them to connect them
to that particular chess club operator
remember so they knew like you know what
that what it was so they so they figured
out that the phone call had come from
the phone box only 400 yards from the
Wallace house which was right by the
tram stop where William Wallace would
have had to get on the tram so some kind
of neighbor when he was going on right
so it was right there and it was right
by the tram so there was a call he was
called yes on this wild goose chase well
yes somebody somebody was somebody in
from their local area right that's okay
survey now we're getting some know they
were thinking okay so the police are
thinking at first
all right here's what happened um you
know the guy bashes his wife's head in
you know wrenches open the safe to make
it look like a robbery then he goes to
the or you know they they are operating
under the assumption that he made the
phone call disguising his voice right
nightmoon or to give himself an alibi
even though Samuel Beatty the guy who
took the phone call at the Chess Club
said I'm sure that wasn't him but you
know he's like he's my friend I know
what his voice sounds like and I don't
think that was you have to set up the
alibi the day before yeah but it could
have been
like some people are saying well it
could have been an accomplice like it
was another guy someone that he hired or
something like that so but they were
going under you know under that
assertion and then he what I'm gonna say
no because an accomplice is a security
breach in other words you have to be
able to trust the accomplice with
knowledge of your homicide right or that
person has to do it so then there's a
bunch of mutual it's too risky to keep
it's you know it's too risky to have an
accomplice to a homicide like this yeah
yeah I'm super super amateur yeah you
know which most of these guys are super
super amateur you know but no any hitman
will tell you that you can't leaving
accomplices is very dangerous so a lot
of times if it got higher as a hitman
the Hitman also kind of thinks about
killing the person who hired him did you
know that well yeah yeah because the
reason yeah because the guy who the
client that hires you is their main
security breach you know yeah security
risk
so here was another thing that made the
police think that maybe William Wallace
did it now underneath Julia's body they
found like a raincoat or Mackintosh type
coat um and it belonged to William
Wallace now they said that now whoever
killed Julia they said they would have
been covered in blood they said there
was blood all over that living room it
was up seven feet on the walls they had
just you know scrapped the [ __ ] out of
her head there was just blood everywhere
okay so they're like so whoever killed
her should have been covered in blood
okay now the interesting thing is that
they went all through the house they
checked all the drains they checked all
the sinks they checked the toilets
nothing no blood so they said whoever
did this could not have cleaned up in
this house they would have had to be
covered with blood
yeah now because the coat was found
underneath her the newspaper said well
what William Wallace did was he put on
he was naked and then he put on the
raincoat and then beat her to death and
then slept out in the raincoat then put
clothes on and then left
like nothing happened that's a lot of
forth there's kind of a problem with
that though
like I said Julia was seen alive by at
least two witnesses maybe more between
6:30 6:45 she seemed fine she talked to
somebody on the doorstep nothing at all
amiss now they said for william wallace
to have been seen where he was seen on
the tram because he was seen by multiple
people on multiple trams they saw him
changing trams they saw him in various
other parts of the city they said now
for him to be on the tram where he was
seen by multiple witnesses he would have
had to leave the house no later than 649
they're like her he wouldn't have been
able to get on there so like this is a
52 year old man he had a life lifelong
kidney ailment he was in very very poor
health there like there is no way that
this guy beat the [ __ ] out of his wife
stole somehow cleaned all this a
wrenched open the thing and then ran
down to the tram stop everything there's
just no way to steal his own money to
steal his own but to make it look like
that so again there's this whole thing
where it and Raymond Chandler obviously
the very famous crime writer or mystery
writer he actually he loved this case
and he wrote a lot about it and he calls
it he so he calls this the impossible
murder he's like Wallace couldn't have
done it but neither could anyone else
that's what he says now did did did he
have insurance policy on his wife um he
did but it was very small it wasn't
anything worth killing anyone over um
you know like I said and he was an
insurance agent so you'd think if he was
gonna do that then he would know the ins
and outs and he would know maybe how to
do it without getting caught but they
said yeah she didn't have a sip but it
was very very so it was like the 20
pounds which is like three weeks wages
yes he had he would have had no
financial motive there was no financial
motive right the only motive he could
have had was just to get rid of the old
lady right but then again he wasn't a
spring chicken self so it's not like he
was running after some 25 year old and
they could never could find any any
evidence that either one of them was
having an affair I have seen sources say
that Julia was like paying some
there guy for sex or something but I
don't know that's it that seems a little
far-fetched I mean she was the old lady
um you know I'm not saying old ladies
like to get freaky too but you know what
I'm saying it just seems like I know the
only thing I know is that based on the
evidence everything about the yeah
there's more there's more there's more
okay why now all the thing I only think
I can come up with now is that there
must have been a neighbor that knew
about the safe somehow and some people
are saying okay so here's they killed
him and slip back up Joe's apartment
it's like some who lived by next door
right that close like I said so maybe
they had time to clean it they could
just go with blood drenched clothing
next door and get in there and clean all
right like maybe two black back alleys
Yeah right yeah now the interesting
thing - yeah like they found no blood in
the house they said they found the only
blood they found the house was this tiny
tiny tiny little clot that was like you
know by the toilet or something they
said that couldn't be linked to anything
there's like obviously it would have
been the person that did it would have
been like super bloody and they're like
you know and nobody cleaned off they
didn't find anything in any of the
drains or nothing and no footprints nope
nothing like that
that's weird there were blood there was
blood everywhere yeah nobody stepped in
it yeah they said it was well they said
it was just all over the wall it was
splattered all over the walls and they
said whoever killed her it would have
been splattered all over them as well
and that's weird there was no no blood
was on the floor nobody ever saw mention
because you would think that you know
there be also be blood splatter on the
floor and then the killer would have
been walking in it yeah you think yeah
and the weird thing too is that both
doors like I said if well if William
Wallace didn't do it when he came home
from his crazy errand you know both the
doors were locked or so he said so I
don't know if the person had a key or if
they just locked it in the left or
whatever you know what if I lock it from
the inside shell yeah maybe you could so
maybe it was that type of thing
now because of the [ __ ] about oh well
you know maybe he just was naked and he
put on the thing and and maybe all these
people were lying about seeing him and
blah blah blah um William Wallace
actually did get arrested and charged
with the murder of his wife the trial
only lasted four days and he was found
guilty and they said and the census is
1930s Britain they did not [ __ ] around
they said
you were gonna hang and the date for the
execution was only a month away
however in pretty much an unprecedented
move for that part because it seemed
like the judge wasn't buying it they
said the problem was that William
Wallace was kind of not a real
gregarious like not a real socially
outgoing type of guy you know he had
those little round glasses which
reminded a lot of people of dr. Crippen
you know the serial killer and they said
that he seemed very um not he's not like
he didn't care but he just seemed very
very calm like on the stand so they
thought that was a little weird so they
they think that might have had something
to do with the conviction because there
wasn't a hell of a lot of evidence they
just couldn't think of anyone else who
would have done it or who would have had
a reason to but he did get convicted but
then later on the judge was like nah
it's like that's there's not enough
evidence that's ridiculous so he
overturned it like before the execution
like so he wasn't actually in prison so
William Wallace wasn't actually in
prison that long and they actually just
let him out so the thing is even if he
did kill his wife like I said he didn't
get any financial gain from it he didn't
really get much of anything from it
because after uhm you know after he got
released everyone still thought he did
it he had to get moved to another job in
another town because everyone hated him
and he died only two years later from
his kidney ailment which he had since he
was a child like I said he was in very
bad health so it's not like he really
got anything out of it if he did kill
her right now the interesting thing
about it is that here's the thing if
William Wallace didn't do it then who
did now the most commonly put forward
person is this fella named Perry he's
less Richard Gordon Perry now I think
this dude probably did it I don't know
if he did it with Williams help or if he
just did it on his own
but listen to this [ __ ] so Richard
Gordon Perry had worked with William
Wallace at Prudential he was stealing
money from the company right a little
bit here a little bit there embezzling
William Wallace found out about it and
he reported it to his superiors I mean
they were friends but he's told his
super he's kind of like you know dipping
his hand in the till you might want to
look into that dude didn't get fired but
he did gotta get um you know quietly
moved to another department Richard
Gordon Perry was actually quite good
friends with Julia was quite good
friends with both of them had been to
the house on numerous occasions also
since William Wallace was in bad health
a lot had to call out sick a lot of
times Richard Gordon Perry often covered
William Wallace's route so he knew about
the money collection he knew where the
safe was
he would have been led into the house if
he came over because Julia knew him very
well
um you know what I mean and he knew the
land at the house he'd been there many
times he also interestingly um he hung
out at the same cafe where William
Wallace's chess club met he would have
seen William Wallace's name on the chess
club thing he also was in an acting
troupe and was quite well known for
doing funny voices and calling people as
pranks so some people think that it's
quite possible that he was the one that
made the call and said hey I'm RM
qualtrix issed
just so that William Wallace would be
out of the house how far away did he
live from there I'm not sure actually I
don't think it was that far okay but see
that's the thing if he could have made
that call you know from that phone box
right there and then he could have
watched to make sure that he went out
and [ __ ] like that um like I said I
don't know if because here's the thing
like some people said it may be William
Wallace like paid him to kill her for
whatever reason but I I don't know if I
buy that one because Gordon Perry
Richard Gordon Perry was actually kind
of note he was
jung-hee was much younger than they were
about half their age I believe he was
kind of like what they call in Britain a
Jack the lad he was very he had like a
really flash like expensive car he spent
a lot more money than he earned that
type of thing like a psychopath so yes
so he actually if he had been paid to
kill her
there was nothing indicating that he had
come into a large deal of you know a
large amount of money
there was nothing weird in William
Wallace's accounts that showed that he
took out a bunch of money like you said
he might have paid him in another way
you know but I there was no it didn't
seem like an audience being exchanged it
seems to me I think he did it on his own
I kind of feel like and they think that
he might have had an accomplice a guy
named Marsden
Richard Marston who also knew Julia so
if these two guys had rolled up to their
house and said hey we got to tell you
something your husband or something like
that she would have let them in she knew
them very well they had been over house
40 they've been alike all the time like
he was a you know a work colleague I
think he thought there was a lot more
money in that safe than there really is
he probably thought there was a [ __ ] ton
of money in there and I yeah and he
calls his buddy out on a call to get rid
of one person he goes well it's just
just hers in there you know to me and
he'd just knock her off you know what I
think though or maybe he didn't know she
was in there that's what I suspect I
don't think he went in there meaning to
kill her necessarily yeah I think what
happened like I said I I'm leaning
toward William Wallace yeah a lot of the
[ __ ] he did was weird like the hey you
know where's this address and where's
like like he was trying to get people to
see him but that might have been just
because he was spazzing out he's like
maybe he was where he's like he wanted a
commission and he's like where is this
address and he was like oh I've done
that you know maybe he just was kind of
like Wiggin out that guy did it so and
like I said I don't like there's no
motive it's like it just seems like he
wouldn't had time to do it he's like son
sounds like something a two-bit thief
who knew him like I said before somebody
that knew both of them so I've got a
two-bit thief checks out that guy
right there you're talking about yeah
his work partner and he probably didn't
know the woman would be in there either
that or he thought he could talk or he
thought that he could do it while she
wasn't looking like I kind of feel like
what happened he went in there disguised
well no because she wouldn't have let
him in then yeah true I kind of feel
like I don't think he intended to kill
her now the reason that I've read this I
can't remember where where I saw this
but evidently the parry would have known
that Tuesday was the day that Wallis
would the the most money would be in the
safe because that was the day that the
week's thing came in or whatever I've
seen that somewhere so I'm not really
sure because you know some people are
like well why you know why would he call
like on the Monday night why would he
just go on the Monday night when he knew
that William Wallace was at the Chess
Club because he saw him leave evidently
if he was the one that made the phone
call you know what I mean so but Tuesday
was apparently the day when their
returns came in and he would go and put
it in the safe which which Perry would
have known because like I said he filled
in for Wallace all the time because
Wallace was very sickly so I kind of
feel like either Perry and just Perry by
himself or Perry and this alleged
accomplice whose name was Richard
Marsden they roll up to the house and
they're like hey we just thought we'd
drop by and see you Julia what's up and
you know she's in the living room making
tea and we're like hey we're just gonna
go in the kitchen for a second we got to
do something and then like trying to
wrench the thing open then she walks in
is like what the [ __ ] are you doing and
then they beat the [ __ ] out of her yeah
I don't think they went in there
intending to kill her maybe either that
or they didn't expect her to be home
like maybe they thought she would go
with him you can on that you know
excursion you rip open us you come up to
somebody's house though unannounced
alright it's like a big deal and then
you steal from the safe and then leave
they're gonna know that you you did it
yeah I think maybe it was just I think
you might be overestimating the guy it
could be that just you know this is know
we'll get him out of the house and we'll
kill that woman and take that money yeah
it could be good have been yeah yeah
she's old anyway yeah sure you know
don't ever know it was us yeah we'll
make it quick
and they're like well something you know
it's not gonna be much maybe someone
beat you know thousand pounds you know
but that'll pay off that'll help me pay
the car that kind of yeah you know it
probably just psychopaths well nobody
sees it we didn't do it though is that
it seems weird to me that if it was them
when they got the safe open and they saw
that there was only four pounds in there
or at least that's how much Wallace said
was in there he said it was only four
pounds which I know is a lot more money
back then than it is now but I mean it's
still not that's still not very much but
the weird thing too is that even after
they killed Julia you know she had a
handbag right there that had money in it
maybe they didn't want to waste time
looking through there cuz you think it's
like oh she's measly four pounds what
else if they got I think the guy was
working alone alright yeah and I think
he was delusional you know he thought
there was thousands of pounds in that
safe maybe sometimes there was yeah it
just hadn't been a very good week his
imagination ran away with him he's like
man it must be a lot of money in there
yeah and then he killed the woman and
looked it wasn't much in their needs
like damn you know he just left he knew
there was gonna be thousands of pounds
in her purse true and maybe was a
traumatic event for him killing the
woman so he didn't want to go back near
to the body and just didn't just didn't
cross his mind
yeah maybe check the purse cuz he was
just so focused on the safe yeah and
then you know gets the safe open and
there's quite a disappointment although
maybe there is something that we don't
know about maybe there was thousands of
pounds in the safe
maybe that guy maybe that maybe there
was stolen money in there and the guy
didn't want to confess I want to fess up
yeah there might have been during there
then he said he stole money together
yeah it could be maybe maybe they had
been fleeced in that company for years
and there may have been five to ten
times yeah pounds no you don't know I
say maybe he didn't want to rat out on
himself yeah there may be more
I should add to that something that kind
of is sort of bolstering the whole maybe
it was Perry type thing in 1981 this
dude named John parks comes forward and
he says you know back in 1931 I worked
at an all-night garage and I was friends
with Perry on the night of the murder
murder
Perry come drives into my
Raaj very freaked out and says get the
high powered water hose and wash my car
off like wash my car out now John Park
said that he looked inside the car and
he saw a glove in there and it was
covered with blood and he says that
Perry said to him if the police see that
I'm gonna hang that he said that quote
unquote
now the interesting thing about this I'm
not sure how seriously I want to take
this I mean because one thing this is 50
years later Park said that the reason
that he didn't you know say anything
about it before then was because he was
waiting for Perry to die because he was
actually kind of afraid of him because
he was a thug so he's like I didn't want
to say anything before cuz I thought
he'd killed me too um and another thing
too is that Park said that Perry said
something about I had to get rid of an
iron bar like dropping it down like a
drain or something like that now two of
the things that were missing from the
house and one of them one of them was
thought to be the murder weapon there
was an iron bar and a fireplace poker
now interestingly the iron bar allegedly
or so I read was actually found later on
it would fallen like behind the
fireplace thing like when they were
renovating the house they found it and
there was no blood on it so that was not
the murder weapon
so they're assuming that the fireplace
poker was the murder weapon because that
was never found
now park said and I'm not sure how
accurate this is Park said that Perry
had said something about getting rid of
the iron bar so I don't know the fire
poker is an iron bar but like I said he
might have just been referring to the
poker right so so there's that whole
thing - so there is another witness even
though it was fifty years until this guy
came forward and said anything because
he said he was afraid of the guy yeah he
said that guy came into my garage and
he's like and I knew him I'd known him
since childhood so I knew who he was and
he came in and he's there was blood
inside his car and there was a glove in
there his blood on it and he said
something about you know the police
better not see that or I'm gonna hang
and he said something about getting rid
of an iron bar like dropping it down a
drain or something like that so I kind
of suspect that maybe Perry had
something to do with it like I said I
don't think Wallace knew I think
what happened was Perry called him
pretending to be somebody else cuz like
I said that was something he was known
to do he pranked people he would call
him do funny voices and he was an actor
and [ __ ] like that so I think he did
that to make sure he was gonna be out of
the house particularly on that Tuesday
because he knew that that's when the you
know the most money would be in the safe
and then I don't know like I said I
don't know if he intended to kill Julia
the whole time or if it just kind of
happened when he went in there and he
didn't know she was gonna be there so he
said well I guess I got a bumper off now
you know what I mean
so I don't know I I don't know I feel
like Wallace probably didn't do it he
didn't get anything out of it I don't
feel like and I don't there's no way he
could have done it just no way because
the times just don't add up you know
could he have like I said ask Perry for
a favor like hey you bump off my wife
I'll make up this whole car I think
Perry just did it because he thought
there's a bunch of ready to save maybe
there was a bunch of money in the safe
yeah like I said and you know they
didn't want to fess up to it I mean
here's the thing though if if you're
gonna do this if you're gonna do an
alibi like this why do one that's that
convoluted that you know it necessitates
all of these strangers remembering you
remembering what time it was that they
saw you there's an easier way you just
like why didn't he just hang out at the
Chess Club where everybody knew him but
you know what I mean if he wanted an
alibi because then he'd be everybody's
like yeah we saw him he was here the
whole time and he couldn't have done it
why like run around the city like
talking to strangers who might not even
[ __ ] remember you why don't you kill
your wife and then tie yourself up right
I think yeah easier ways I could've done
this and I mean the thing is it's like
everybody it's funny because if you see
some of the newspapers from the time
like the press made a big deal about oh
he's like this big chess master and he
like you know he they couldn't checkmate
him and all this others so cuz he got
away with it like he was this big genius
but everybody that knew him at the chess
club was like yeah he loved playing
chess but he was really shitty like he
wasn't some [ __ ] mastermind or
anything like that
so I kind of feel like I feel like
he got played honestly I feel like Perry
played him I feel like he was gonna
steal the money and he's also kind of
getting revenge on Wallace read my route
and for ratting him out like I said he
didn't get fired but he did get in
trouble yeah like for embezzling so
maybe he said well [ __ ] you man I'm just
gonna you know what I mean so it would
have been easy for him to do that he
knew his movements he knew all of that
kind of [ __ ] Perry fits the bill you
produce so I kind of feel like he
probably did it I don't think Wallace
had anything to do with it and I know
people are probably gonna disagree with
me on that but I kind of lean toward
because like I said why would you
they've been married for 17 years you
think he was gonna kill her he'd do it
he's a little old to be killing his wife
but yeah so I I don't know I just kind
of feel like if anybody wants to debate
about it like I said I've been reading
like all kind of different [ __ ] about
the funny thing to PD James she's a
crime writer and her big thing was that
the call and the murder didn't have
anything to do with each other that it
was just like a weird coincidence and
then people are like oh well how do you
explain like the milk guy and the paper
guy like seeing Julia on the doorstep PD
James says oh well maybe William had
already killed her and he and he dressed
up as her I'm like William Wallace was a
foot taller than his wife and had a
mustache and was skinny she was 5 foot 3
and kind of plump yeah it's like I don't
think anybody is gonna buy that he was
you know what I mean the milk guy knew
what she looked like he came there every
week so I'm just like yeah I'm not
buying that I'm just not buying it and I
don't think that there's any way that he
could have done it because they said
there's no way he could have killed her
cleaned himself up and then left the
house and got on the tram because
everybody saw him on the tram I'd say
Perry did I think Perry did it too
I don't know about the other guy like I
said Marsden they think that maybe he
had an accomplice but I don't know it
might have been just him I think just
Perry did it cuz usually money there was
money in there it's just you know it was
just something mundane he thought he
could get some money yeah and killed her
yeah yeah and like I said I don't know
if he intended to kill her if he didn't
intend to kill her but you know if he
was headed he was probably killing two
birds with one stone he's getting
revenge and stealing
bunch of money or what he thought was a
bunch of money at the same time so I'm
kind of leaning toward Perry in this I
think he did I think he didn't it I
think well I think he knew he's gonna
have to kill her
yeah yeah yep some people have also just
as a little coda some people have also
thought that maybe the neighbor John
Johnston was maybe the killer because he
had a key to the house and you know so
some people of them some city maybe I'm
going to go steal this and robbed the
safe it turns out she was they had to
kill her now interestingly when John
Johnston was on his deathbed he
allegedly confessed to killing Julia
Wallace well but she but he had like
dementia okay so they don't know how
seriously to take that but some people
have said maybe they should have been
looked into they weren't really looked
into at the time they were investing a
little bit but not really so you know it
could have been them like I said they
did have a key to the house and that's
you know they could have gotten very
easily they knew the couple very well so
might have been them - I don't know but
I kind of feel like Perry is a more it's
probably a more viable suspect I would
think he had a lot more motive yeah to
do it than criminal history now it
should be noted - that it's rumored that
the neighbors moved away the day after
the murder but I think I'd move away too
if somebody got murdered next door you
know what I mean I don't think that's
that weird I don't think that
necessarily but they're guilty or
anything like that but I just thought I
would mention that because some people
have said hey maybe they should look
into the like [ __ ] it we're out of here
yeah well yeah like I said somebody got
what battered to death like and you
don't know who it was like like that I'd
leave - yeah but yeah so you know like I
said debate it in the comments and we'll
see if anybody agrees with mana they're
not so I guess that will do it for our
old-time true crime
double feature episode hope you guys
enjoyed it and remember if you like the
show - like share subscribe on all your
social media if you'd like to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page at patreon.com slash
13 o'clock podcasts or go to our blog
which is 13 o'clock podcast WordPress
comm and there's a link in the sidebar
to a PayPal account if you'd like to
give a one-time donation and be much
appreciated also check out our last
movie
perspective which was nos Faraci the
vampire Verna Hertzog from 1979 so go
check that out also check out our latest
matinee what did we review on their
Overlord over the spider's web and the
Grinch so go check that out too and also
I liked it and also go check out our
Azazel store in sisal calm / 13 o'clock
is bunch of cool t-shirts and a tote bag
and that'll do it for episode 118 we
will see you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]